all right if you don't get your shopping
done today small businesses are hoping
you turn to them tomorrow Black Friday
fever will transition to small business
Saturday and several owners believe
those sales could determine their future
as Christmas time comes everybody just
seems to forget about the insanity and
you just feel everybody's Joy Tiana
Barber has been operating her health and
healing company in downtown Summerlin
since 2016. everybody just kind of
relaxes and just strolls through enjoys
their time she claims the holiday
shopping season is crucial to stay open
especially small business Saturday and
that's how we save up our money and put
us into the new year her team has been
pulling in long hours since many of her
products are made fresh offering
customers samples at the door to learn
business Black Friday is a big day for
us a few feet away Crystal Chase also
trying to grow her business in the midst
of being surrounded by big box stores
she says the key is the value customers
get shopping Smalls about the experience
from everything from the free gift wrap
that we offer to the curated pieces to
the events that we plan for our
community
um we we try to really get in touch with
our community and they love us back for
it according to the U.S Small Business
Association there are an estimated 33
million small businesses in the country
about 1.7 million of veterans will shop
over the holiday weekend giving
businesses like these a boost you can
shop for food you can see Santa you can
go ice skating with your family and make
really great memories and then you can
come in and see some really cute gifts
and do your Christmas shopping with us
how do they get your attention
um kind of just the signs I guess like
the names that you know
for this group of Shoppers their work is
just getting started we're kind of
shopping for ourselves just treating the
four of us